- Everybody in my family catches lobster.
Me and my sister are
fourth-generation lobstermen.
Throughout these generations
of all of us lobstering,
the lessons I've learned
about sustainability are,
if we don't protect it now,
then we're not gonna have
it in the future.
I'm Heather Thompson. I am Captain
of fishing vessel Gold Digger.
With my sister Hillary as my sternman.
My great-grandfather was a lobsterman,
my grandfather was a lobsterman,
my dad is a lobsterman,
my two sons are lobstermen, and my niece
is a lobstermen.
My name is Laney, and I'm a fifth
generation lobster fisherman.
- [Heather] It's what we all do.
It's really, it's a
physically demanding job.
I mean, you have to worry about the tides,
bait, getting your
rope, buoys, your traps,
so many things, it's even hard to fathom
until you actually have to go and do it.
One of the sayings my father
used to say was “Be somebody.”
You know, it doesn't matter
if, if we were a guy
or a girl on the back, it's
like, if you wanna do it,
you can do it.
You just have to make sure
you push yourself. Be somebody.
Do it.
He's taught me just
about everything I know,
especially the
sustainability of lobster,
making sure that we're
protecting our own future.
and my children's
generation to catch lobster.
We plan to do this the rest of our lives,
if it allows us.
- Lobster fishermen have
been practicing sustainable
fishing for many generations,
before the regulations
even came into effect.
- We inspect every single
lobster we pull aboard.
If it's undersized, we throw it back,
and if it's oversized, we throw it back.
- [Skip] We want the
resource to be sustainable,
and if we take the big
ones and harvest them,
then there's not lobster
for future generations.
- [Heather] When we pull
up a lobster that has eggs
on it, we take our tool,
and we make a little nick
in its tail, we call it V-notch;
it makes a little V in the fin.
- [Skip] That means you throw it back
because it's an egg-bearing female.
And that's important for
the future sustainability
of the lobster population.
- Our future is worth more than that.
- [Skip] We're really
appreciative of the job
the fishermen do day in and day out.
It's a tough job, and we
establish face-to-face
meetings with them so we can
understand their business,
who their family is, and
what their challenges
and opportunities are.
It helps us to keep the resource
vibrant for future years.
And it helps them meet our needs
and get the highest quality seafood.
- If we don't take care of our future,
then nobody else will.
It's our kid's future.
- My grandfather always
told me to be somebody.
It means to, like, work hard
and do your best at whatever you do.
And the name of my boat is Be Somebody.
- For these 50 years,
throughout these generations
of all of us lobstering, my
great-grandfather practiced
sustainability of lobsters.
He protected the lobsters
he threw back to ensure that my generation
and my children's generation would be able
to catch lobster.
When a lobster is put on somebody's plate
and brought to them, and they look at it,
I want them to think of
how much of a tradition,
and how much time and effort and thought
went into this catch.
It's a lot of generations,
a lot of learning,
a lot of hard work, a lot of
time, that went into that.